nothing changes
we continue with the rescue mission
we're just going to ignore dev
give me an updated state vector for the
russian vessel
you got a problem danny
yes ed danny does have a problem in fact
he has many of them hey guys pete here
today i'll be talking about episode 4 of
for all mankind's third season which
managed to pack quite a few twists and
turns into another solid episode happy
valley kept up the excitement of the
race to mars that kicked off in the
final minutes of the previous episode
and by the time we got to the end we had
a new crisis and that may have given
birth to an unlikely alliance i'll be
going through all of that and what i
thought about it right after this quick
spoiler warning if you haven't seen the
fourth episode of for all mankind's
third season then this video isn't for
you and with that out of the way let's
get into it
in the opening of the episode you see
all three ships in transit ed is in high
spirits when he contacts helios mission
control to tell them that they've
crunched the numbers and there's no way
the other ships can catch them now they
believe they've won the race they'll be
the first to mars and it looks like his
old employer nasa will be the last to
get there he tells his boss debbie essa
that it's time to celebrate as they're
going to win this interstellar
exploration prize which i guess has a
pretty big amount of money attached to
it dev declares that he won't be keeping
the money for himself that he'll split
it evenly amongst all of helios staff
and you see that karen and bill are awed
by his generosity things are looking
good for the upstart private space
program in his words they beaten the
world's super powers at their own game
danielle makes a call to the phoenix to
concede the race to her former commander
and his crew and he makes the comment
that innovation and out-of-the-box
thinking win the day every time this all
turns out to be a setup because nasa
still has one more trick up its sleeve
after telling kelly to fire up a shanty
on her ipod which didn't come out in our
timeline until 2001 they unfurl a
massive solar sail which will change the
race and get them there 8 days before
everyone else it's clear no one
anticipated this and when dev asks his
staff how they can retake the lead he
finds out that they can't at least not
without doing something extremely
dangerous karen tries to reason that
getting there first isn't more important
than getting there in one piece and
let's just say deb disagrees for him
it's the only thing that matters and to
make his point he smashes a monitor on
the ground before walking out of the
room we've all been kind of expecting
there to be a darker side to deb and his
motivations and that definitely comes
back up before the end of the episode
there's a nice scene where danielle
calls ed to gloat a little and even
though he's crushed their personal
history and the surprise of nasa's
innovation leaves him with no choice but
to congratulate her on her win and for
her to say she learned from the best
after the opening credits we see some of
the newscasts about how the sale changed
the race and the response from roscosmos
who maintained that the soviets can and
will still get there first which seems
pretty unlikely because neither of the
other two teams had been mentioning them
as a threat you also get a closer look
at this backlash to the transition to
helium-3 and fusion energy that also
comes up in president ellen's meeting
with the speaker of the house who's a
democrat that she has to deal with to
get her budget approved they're trying
to strike a grand bargain to balance the
budget and to show the people that
bipartisanship works but this idea of
nasa being massively profitable without
sharing is in his words causing blowback
from his constituents but he's likely
also referring to the fossil fuel lobby
it's not really clear what the show is
trying to do with this other than show
that ellen is trying to do good in her
position of power but is coming up
against resistance
after the meeting larry senses that
she's stressed so he makes the
suggestion that they go to visit jsc
which she hasn't been to since she won
the election when she arrives there's
more protesters outside and you see that
jimmy stevens is in the crowd he brought
up problems he had with nasa at danny's
wedding so i guess it makes sense for
him to be at this protest where he gets
recognized by a reporter and then a girl
named sunny comes up to introduce
herself and invite him to have beers
with her and her friends afterwards when
they get together you see that her
boyfriend is the moon marine pilot that
tracy was training to fly the l-sam in
season 2. he doesn't believe that the
government is telling the real story of
what happened on the moon which we know
is true but him and his friends have
twisted things around to fit a different
narrative
where rather than covering up a second
reactor this is all about dividing the
moon to split up the helium-3 and there
are some interesting things going on in
this part of the story but it does feel
a little out of place so i'm not sure
how i feel about what's going on here in
space there's a little montage of life
on sojourner and phoenix to give an idea
of what the trip is like things look a
lot more comfortable on the ladder we
even see ed jogging around thanks to the
spin gravity but we do see that morale
is high under danielle's command even if
it is just the quiet before the storm on
phoenix the crew are drinking brews and
messing around and the lioness who
showed tracy jamestown for the first
time when she first arrived is acting
out a scene from the movie about tracy
and gordo when danny walks in this leads
to a confrontation where he sort of
pushes him around and pressures him into
doing this other scene from the movie
which is uncomfortable for everyone and
then ed shows up to break it up he
stresses that he needs danny to lead by
example after all this is the reason
that he wanted to bring him in the first
place to straighten him out to give him
a purpose and he'll need him to control
his temper to do that which all feels
like foreshadowing for something bad
that'll happen before the trip is over
at jsc ellen enters mission control and
gets her photo op in a standing ovation
she doesn't have to pretend to be
thrilled to be back it's clear that it
makes her emotional margot sort of pulls
elena aside and says it never changes
the people at nasa do all the hard work
but the politicians grab the glory when
elena points out that ellen's one of
them margot is quick to warn her that
she's not anymore ellen gives a moving
speech about how they pulled things
together how they worked as a team to
beat helios and when she thanks them for
their service to their country you see
margot drop her head with the tinge of
shame and this along with a lot of other
hints confirmed that she did have to
help the soviets with their nuclear
engine that engine will be the catalyst
for the episode ending crisis on
sojourner kelly gets a call from a
cosmonaut on mars 94. he warns her that
his commanders are going to do something
very dangerous to try to win the race
and before he can get into the details
he has to get off the call and then you
see them fire up those nuclear engines
they have a plan that would get them
there three days ahead of everyone else
but when their burn doesn't last long
enough it's obvious that they have a
major malfunction
danielle tells ed that their engines are
in meltdown and there's only 72 hours to
make a rescue attempt neither of the
ships have enough fuel to do the rescue
and still make mars orbit so it means
that going after them is also a ticket
home ed realizes that it makes the most
sense for phoenix to do it and is
willing to sacrifice his chance at glory
only when he explains this to helios
mission control everyone who had a
history with nasa is all for it while
deb and his faithful vote to keep going
and let nasa deal with the rescue there
are two flashes here you can't miss
initially danny isn't behind ed's plan
and on the ground karen is starting to
have second thoughts about dev's
motivations and i mentioned in my last
video that in future seasons it was
getting hard to imagine who would be
left at nasa but after seeing this that
extra money might not be as much of an
incentive
when ed finds out what they decided he
decides not to change anything he's
gonna go ahead with the rescue mission
but he finds out that when they sent the
last message they also sent a software
update that locked them out of the
controls dev anticipated that ed
wouldn't follow the order so he took
over the ship and now it's essentially
flying on autopilot the news gets around
and i love that margot suggested
nationalizing his company but in the end
nasa decides to do what needs done they
throw away their mission to mars and set
out to save the cosmonauts lives on the
approach danny tells her crew that the
soviet ship uses the same fuel as
sojourner and asks one of her crew to go
and film the ship to see if houston can
figure out a way to transfer the fuel
over of course when they bring the
cosmonauts over things start to go wrong
elena and margot notice a problem on
earth but because of the time that it
takes a message to get from them to the
crew they aren't able to warn them mars
94 ends up crashing into sojourner two
astronauts and one cosmonaut are killed
and the episode ends with everything up
in the air
there's a lot of interesting things
going on dev's decision changed the
nature of the race and the mars 94
situation sets up the probability of a
joint mission between nasa and the
soviets there is some built-in tension
and having the defector on board doesn't
help but given the circumstances
everyone on the ship will at least be
willing to work together in order to
make it back alive i already felt
confident that the move with sergey at
the iac conference worked to compromise
margot further in all the references to
the soviet engine being similar to
nasa's back that up she appears to be
ashamed and of course she's worried
about getting found out and that all
adds an extra layer to any cooperation
that they have and this opens up more
possibilities helios is in the best
position at the moment but ed won't
react well to what happened there was
already hints at tension building up
with danny and on the ground karen and
bill are second guessing their decision
to come on board there's a lot of
different ways that things can go wrong
and there's still a lot of episodes left
so it's a pretty exciting time to be a
fan of the show this is the one example
of a new season of a tv show where i
wish i hadn't seen the trailer it kind
of makes it hard to speculate on what
comes next because there are some things
that i already know the good news here
though is that things are moving fast
and i imagine that we'll get answers as
to how the rest of the mission to mars
is going to play out for everyone
involved right at the beginning of the
next episode it doesn't feel like
there's a lot of time for things to be
drawn out that means that i do expect
that we'll be getting into new territory
beyond the trailer beyond the obvious
push for everyone to arrive on mars and
then we'll find out what the second half
of the season is going to be all about
i'm pretty happy with the setup all the
way around i thought this was another
good episode that had a little bit of
everything dev got a lot more
interesting the solar sail was a lot of
fun and we got another intense set piece
at the end it continues to be promising
that they seem to pick up on the things
like the questions i was asking last
week and addressing them organically in
this week's episode things like what's
gonna happen to nasa if everyone goes
over to helios and i guess you don't
really need to introduce everyone who's
gonna be on sojourner if two of them are
gonna die right away and that is a nice
bonus that we'll get a little more of
the russian side of things when we bring
these two groups together and i'm
curious to see how they influence each
other while they're working together
this was a pretty fantastic ed episode
if you think about it it really pulled
on all the things that we know about the
character and how he'll react to
different situations to build up a
situation where we aren't a hundred
percent on what he'll do next i really
don't know where they're going with some
of the clean energy stuff and the jimmy
gets involved with conspiracy theory
people
sides of the story i think it's a little
early to tell like i said before i think
there is some interesting stuff they
could do here but i don't think any of
that is working great yet at the same
time it's a little early to tell so
we'll see how that develops i'm looking
forward to next week hopefully they can
keep it up and i think that's a good
place to leave things let me know in the
comments what you're thinking about the
race how it's playing out and what
you're hoping to see in the upcoming
episodes
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon